thank you
[Music]
okay since we're all such experts in
political well no not that but in the
art of uh attraction oh dude me and Nick
are all about negging yeah you guys are
good at that I can't tell you how many
times it's not gonna be useful in this
situation yeah we're gonna flip it
instead of analyzing pick up ours
techniques we're going to analyze pickup
artist techniques made for women trying
to pick up men why would they even need
that yeah just stand there it's so easy
just show them the photo show them the
goods yeah show them the goods any of
them top or bottom uh yeah I think some
need it there you go some girls just
need to brush their teeth though that's
it yeah brush your tongue yo brush your
tongue that's a fact brush your teeth
when you wake up hey can you show us how
you brush your tongue
yeah
looks like he's it looks like he's doing
something else and then my eyes get all
watery and I'm [__] dry heaving in
the morning oh you really go that deep
yeah bro you gotta clean your tongue
what are you guys gross come on well I
don't know how do you do it how do you
do it again he doesn't do it Anthony
doesn't clean his tank you go like this
oh you have a scraper yeah you got a
really red tongue
yeah yeah bird you just got burned bro
hey you know you got a really strong
jawline right Joe oh I should be on that
list he don't gotta that's no weak chin
yeah [__] him in the face let's go God
I'm just 90 chin so so what are these
recommendations for these women thank
you for asking so these are actual
things that a woman has written for
women all right am I Megan and Doug okay
but it's women pickup artist how many
dudes has she slept with
well it's her [__] we need the stats
should it be high or low for should be
high oh okay it should be high if she if
she has all these pickup lines that work
all the time her number she should be
through the roof I don't think her body
counts listed in her uh name all right
we'll hear what this poser has to say
okay so here's here poser a long time
this is just what she's saying okay tip
number one she says to think of sex as a
numbers game
which means if you're trying to get laid
then you just got to keep putting it out
there until you get a bite girls have a
really hard time trying to get laid the
number is two I think we need to get rid
of that stereotype finally I don't think
so you gotta be kidding me I know I feel
the same way I always think that like
you know all women have to do is just
time making sure that the guys that they
want to get like have sex with are like
good guys because all the guys are
[__] out there that's different
you've never had a girl you've never
known any girl that I'm on her side
right now you know what I'm saying she
decide after his statement like
yeah come sit over here yeah bring your
chair over here
okay
the protect the women's side everybody
then you've never had a friend that was
a girl that had intentions that night
and she actually said oh man I want to
get laid tonight and then you didn't
yeah cause she's a loser I wouldn't hang
out with that person you know what I
can't you know what I've heard though it
happens I've heard a lot where some
women have more libido than their
boyfriends and they're just like he just
[__] me geez and I'm like it's like
about Strangers Like would you want to
[__] a stranger like if you're in a
committed relationship that's like a
different thing but if you're like
single and like if you want to go out
there and [__] someone I do think that
well at least
from your example right it it I what I
can remember is that like girls would be
given hints or what they think are hints
and it'll go over the guy's heads so
then they're like I'm trying to get some
dick tonight and then the guy's like yo
man give me an example of like a hint
that would go over a guy's head
no I mean like um please [__] me
they're not straight up enough like
they're like huh yeah they're like what
this is this can't be this can't be we
should do puzzles together oh what did
you know I wanted to [__] you puzzles is
they're at a party what kind of signs do
you get when you know like you're
talking to a young lady after a comedy
show and then she she might say a phrase
where you're like oh it's going down I
heard the phrase throat goat once she
called herself the throat yeah wow
afterwards did you agree with her did
you say oh she was she was quite the
froco uh I actually didn't uh get
anything with her oh okay it was just
theoretical I just had to like you think
she was talking about you she was just
talking about something else she said
she was a throat goat yeah you're like I
don't buy it you're like yeah I'm not
gonna test that at all no thank you like
you must be talking about like doing
this for somebody else yeah yeah
theoretically to a stranger Theory one
of the things that I always thought was
a dead giveaway was when a girl let's
say you're in private and for some
reason she just wants to somehow say
that she hasn't had sex in a long time
absolutely I think that would go over my
head considered a fair hint like why are
we talking about that if she brings it
up and you're not even on the topic I
think that's a pretty fair I think I
think we're guys are obviously too
literal and I think that would go over
my head for sure I'd be like oh that
sucks yeah
you should probably figure that out how
many days it's been huh yeah yeah so
she's so this advice here says if you
get rejected by a guy just go on to the
next one develop a thicker skin about it
that's that's good advice number two is
memorize a few openers
dude this is this doesn't happen this is
this is not a real deal openers are
chicks using openers on you I'd be like
you might have been [__] bizarre ones
memorize memorize one or two natural
sounding lines
what's a good opener group
[Music]
I think that's a little too aggressive
no no I love it it's really direct and
guys like that yeah literally we love
goats Michael Jordan okay
well if a girl uses an opener on me I'd
be like am I on Tinder in Medellin
Colombia
to kill me after this I like how you
listed all men goats but like there's no
woman goats Serena
Earhart yeah Simone biles Joan of Arc
Ryan really likes Amelia
I don't know I don't have female openers
that [__] never happens it's just your
legs okay all right this woman would
have a thing or two to say to you about
that okay yeah let's hear it she got no
she got she got no [__] she doesn't she
doesn't have any suggestions
she's just saying make some memorize it
keep them in the pocket for the quick
draw I think women just going just
entertaining a conversation with a man
initiating it in itself is is an opener
correct because women don't do that so I
think that alone is an opener that's
already giving the guy no no that's too
easy because a lot of times they do that
just get free drinks yeah that's the
example of an opener you've heard of
views on you as a guy you've had to I've
heard an opener at some point Arbor a
long time ago this girl asked me she's
like hey do you want to hook up and I
was like no thank you and then I walked
away
and he's like I don't think that was for
me by the way yeah
I don't think that was about no because
I think when when the very few times
women have been very like forward with
me
I feel like it's going to be a Medellin
situation you're in disbelief
we're gonna rob me or something I was in
my math class and this girl went like
this and I went back and she goes can I
tell you a secret and I'm like what she
goes dude
and then my face went red and I was like
holy [__] this is like a [__] movie
but I'm too scared he said that out loud
in my head
and she was telling me like and it was
subtitles yeah she goes I'm bi and then
like I uh me and my friends like we have
sleepovers and we just eat each other
out all night what the [__] what'd you
do I was scared how old are you like 15
or 16. Roman Atwood in the background
somewhere yeah dude and then I was like
perfect mark look at that [__] idiot
over there go get up go get it go get
him yeah go to the hidden camera here
okay here's what I think is actually
very useful she's saying number three is
make your intentions clear uh if you're
smiling and you you say hey you're cute
we should do something give me your
number that's quoted here see that's a
good line I think it's nice start with
that but dude can you because I've been
the tender age of 13 to 15. I had a
chick when I was in drama and she like
pulled me literally pulled me into a
dark corner and in drama like it's a big
place yeah so you can get pulled into a
place she pulled me in there and she
like started just grabbing my dick
through my shorts and she's like let me
see it Steve Green I've been wanting to
say because you heard of The Legend of
the big Steve Green look at this dude
reviews
[Laughter]
good that was that was after the show
no no so then I was just like and I
walked out of the room yeah I didn't
know what to do I was so [__]
confused it's like a tiger that doesn't
know how to kill its prey yet exactly
he's a tiger cub that's a poem I think
if women are too forward in that way I
think it's like an instant Throne like
am I is like this is a prank am I being
baited like there's so many more
questions to it than it yeah right it's
a rational I like about it is it does
cancel out that feeling that we innately
have societally where we we're afraid of
being creeps so at least if she's the
one going into that realm you don't you
no longer have to feel like oh my
imposing am I being you know this might
not make you interested but I think it
does clear that up number four is use
flirtatious touching
I think girls already do that no yeah
yeah but I think now it's just having an
awareness of The Kino escalation they
call it so who's she talking to girls
that don't have any action at all
because I feel like every [__] girl
does this when they're into you they
just somehow find a way to get closer to
you in proximity and they find a way to
somehow start touching you yeah girls
are so good at that yeah yeah no that's
creepy as [__] if we touch them yeah
yeah yeah yeah or never get in front of
you at all if we touch them it's [__]
weird though you don't ever go with this
move
and then you can do that as much as you
like oh wow how about this this one
Steve goes like
here's my phone it's not a good magic
show it's because your thumb's still up
you don't go like this it's moving
around this one says qualify them do you
know what qualified that means what's
that about like credit check kind of
yeah it says um you want to make guys
feel like you're a little bit of a
challenge so disagree on a few points
they make I agree I agree I agree I
disagree disagree
why argumentative ladies
trying to get laid that's true because I
think a large majority of women are
agreeable by Nature really yeah the
conflict is hot [__] it's hot conflict
conflict is so hot right yeah no because
there's like that disagreement [__] and
then it's like oh I'm gonna [__] it out
of you later like that's that's not for
me it's a game now 100
tell me your name she's just like I
agree I
yeah
I'm sorry I was wrong I think it's it's
also just like uh guys enjoyed the chase
right so um it's not a Chase if they're
not running away a little bit you know
what I'm saying okay I was with an
agreeable chick and it was so [__]
boring I've never been more bored in my
life she was really cool like no hate no
hate but just everything I said no
matter what I should agree but yeah
that's true yeah I'm like yeah dude the
reichstag fire was like [__] like
awesome like yeah it was like had some
cool ideas
that's legitimately overdoing your own
views and she's just like yes exactly no
you I was not quite going to there that
actually but I was like just testing
[__] out I was like God forget it and
like that's what I mean like Nikki
breaks my balls all [__] day and I
love it yeah that's your love language
though you know that's true that makes
sense here's the last one just to skip
over to it but it kind of makes sense
don't overdo it if you go to a venue
talk to a maximum of Five Guys per night
it's not hidden so she says try a bunch
but like only up to five well because
you don't want to look desperate having
a number is desperate
having having lines written out in your
pocket it's desperate that's desperate
it's just it's prepared I guess
imagine imagine a guy came up to you and
was like you saw him reading something
in his hand and then he was like but he
looks like Dion Cole and then and then I
well that's kind of his thing though if
he looks like the uncle he has that's
his thing so I think
no but imagine it's like how we met like
the story how we met and then she's like
I was number five he had flash cards
which is nice forget it it's gonna sound
[__] up but I think it's for
unattractive girls because everything
I'm still thinking of that you know why
because like when I when I've gone like
in groups two lounges to bars to clubs
anything right well at this point go all
of the girls seven times it's so [__]
like someone's always hitting on them
like they don't have to do these things
he's like this article is for ugly
[__]
you don't got to be fine you you just
got to be a [__] girl
geez she left one thing off of that list
even hippos [__] would jump
that's what Joe's trying to say the one
thing off that list is um when you're
going out that night make sure that the
friend that you're going with your
homegirl is uglier
all right that's what he said
turn it off now